le titre du film c'est le petit homme
l'histoire c'est celle d'un enfant
génial sa mère qu'il reste avant tout un
enfant son professeur veut qu'il soit
avant tout génial et l'enfant lui que
veut-il c'est le thème du premier film
réalisé donc par jodie foster dominique
poncet mari allan rock temps
je de 50 films je savais toujours sur
platon que c'était job que je peux mais
je ne pensais pas que je suis assez mûrs
quand j'ai halluciné ce scénario là ça
m'a tout de suite obsédé et puis j'ai
passé des mois on pensait que je disais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec ce film
alors c'est le signe ce film sur
l'histoire d'un enfant surdoué jodie
foster n'aura porté pendant deux ans
depuis la réécriture du scénario jusqu'à
la réalisation en passant par la
production et l'interprétation
pourquoi cet investissement d'abord
parce qu'ayant été elle-même une enfant
star d'hollywood
jodie foster s'est un peu reconnue dans
ce petit homme ensuite parce que le
scénario lui offrait un rôle inédit
celui de maman être à la fois devant et
derrière la caméra ne lui a pas trop
poser de problème c'est ça qui dansent
sur ce taux est bien sûr c'est difficile
mais mais mais il faut dire que
d'ailleurs j'ai jamais voulu faire un
film où je devais jouer en même temps
que diriger mais j'avais pas le choix
c'était la meilleure façon de faire
financer et sinon le film ne serait pas
faire financer par la suite mais à la
fin ce que j'ai trouvé ce que ça m'a
aidé énormément ça m'aidait avec ma
relation avec le garçon qui joue et mon
fils parce qu il savait que la personne
qui me dirigeais c'était aussi la mère
qui le protégeait
c'est aussi que moi j'étais une actrice
comme lui alors s'il faisait lui aussi
il pourrait le faire et personnes
allaient se monte lui choisi parmi des
centaines d'enfants à new york
le petit adam and bear participe pour
beaucoup à la réussite de ce film
sensible et rigoureux qui plaide pour
que les petits surdoué et droit à une
vie normale